Dr. Jen Simmons did a podcast with Dr. David Broadstein on iodine recently. She said that she has
converted to his way of thinking on iodine since talking with him. I've not listened to that
particular podcast, but I do know that Dr. Broadstein believes it is not just okay, but important for
those with Hashimoto's tab, adequate iodine to support the thyroid. I was on it previously,
it had been off of it for about a year and feel worse without it. What are your thoughts?
So, well, my thoughts are, you can disagree with me, but I disagree with Dr. Broadstein.
Dr. Broadstein follows basically the old naturopathic, nutritional, functional,
or functional medicine thought process that I used to follow too, that iodine is essential
for the thyroid. Therefore, anybody wants to support the thyroid should be on iodine.
Because the thyroid takes iodine to make its T3 and T4,
T3 and T4 iodine is a functional part of that. Therefore, it goes with understanding that
anybody should be on iodine to help support the thyroid in making thyroid hormone, the T3 and T4.
However, study after study after study in the last 10 years have shown that
people are getting adequate iodine in their food and the whole light of thinking about iodine was
that was because in the 1940s and 50s, there were a large populace of people that were iodine
deficient. We weren't getting it in our food because you were eating locally and in the 40s and
50s, people had moved away from eating vegetation. So people weren't eating vegetables as much.
They were eating, that's when after World War II, the easy TV dinners came out and our food
quality plummeted from prior to World War II. Prior to World War II, people were growing things
in the gardens. It was encouraged for people to grow their meals, grow enough food. Putting them up,
counting was very popular. And families were eating foods that they were producing. They were
producing foods on the farm. In the 50s, things changed dramatically post World War II and then we saw
a dramatic rise in nutritional deficiencies that we never saw before. Chemicals were used on plants
and nutritional value of plants themselves that people were eating had plummeted. It was said that
the nutritional value of an orange prior to World War II had 50 times the nutritional value that
an orange does today. So our nutritional value of food has changed dramatically and you could read
a lot about that data in its straight science. So there were people that were deficient in iodine.
Matter fact, there was a part of America that was called the iodine belt that people were getting
iodine. That's why they started to put iodine in salt. Unfortunately, they put potassium iodine in salt.
That's the source of iodine that they used. It's not a good source of iodine and that's what most
iodine supplements are, are potassium iodine. It's not a good source of iodine for our body anyhow.
So it was the light of thinking from nutritionists from the 1960s, late 60s,
on that everybody should be taking iodine and you should be making sure that you're taking salt
that is iodized salt because that's how you could get your iodine. So that light of thinking has
continued by a lot of people. Dr. David Brown said it kind of has an ore in the water because he wrote
at least one book on the necessity of iodine and he would in order to change this thinking
you have to recant everything that she wrote in that book. Now I'm not saying that there can't be
some truth that there's still people that are deficient in iodine and need a source of iodine,
but if that was the case, then I would be taking a whole food source of iodine, not a potassium iodine
that's in 99% of supplements out there. But I would before taking iodine, I would test if I had
iodine deficiency. The problem has come up is that prior to the use of potassium iodine supplementation
and iodized salt, there really was no autoimmune thyroid. People did have, so understand thyroid
problems. You can have primary hypo thyroidism. That means you just have a low functioning thyroid.
You don't have an autoimmune disease to the thyroid. You don't have elevated TPO antibodies.
You don't have elevated thyroid globulin antibodies. So not having those antibodies,
you don't have an autoimmune attack on the thyroid. What caused autoimmune thyroidism,
Hashimoto's, and caused it to spike in the 70s, 80s, 90s to its current state is the use of iodine.
There was several studies on taking people with primary hypo thyroidism, giving them iodine
and the studies were just, you can't argue with the data. Every single person with primary hypo thyroidism
taking iodine, develop Hashimoto's. So when you have Hashimoto's, it's a total new game.
So once you have Hashimoto's and you're taking iodine, iodine is so drawn to the thyroid,
is that you will stimulate an immune attack on the thyroid, taking iodine. Once you already have
Hashimoto's, so it will make your Hashimoto's worse. Can a person actually, I was taking iodine
and I felt better? Well, I would say maybe that's true. I'm not questioning your subjective data there,
but I would say maybe you should question whether there was other factors that you don't feel as well.
That are indifferent to the iodine. Maybe I'm completely wrong there in your case and maybe you need
iodine. I'm not, I'm not saying that, but the data is, it's very specific that iodine will stimulate
an immune attack on the thyroid for those that already have Hashimoto's. If you don't have Hashimoto's,
it will almost surely create a Hashimoto's and autoimmune thyroid condition to somebody who has
primary hypothyroidism. I'm not going to argue with Dr. Brownstein. I'm not going to argue with
Jensinins, but the data is very specific and I do have much more on this on the autoimmune course.
You guys all have access to that. In the last section, the last module of the autoimmune course
is all on thyroid Hashimoto's disease so you could gather more information on that. I do have
some of the studies I think published out there as well.